Now a mistake that a lot of people make
is to confound slope and correlation.
In other words, if they find that
the slope of the line fits the data is 1,
that the data are correlated,
and that's not true.
The slope is just the slope.
Correlation is a measure of
how tightly do these individual
points fit that line?
So you could have a shallow slope but
the data tightly fitting that line,
and thus a higher correlation.
Or you could have a steeper line and
the data fitting that line
at a higher correlation.
Correlation is just a measure of how
tightly do those dots fit the line.
And you can have
a correlation from 0 to 1.
0 meaning it's not correlated at all,
And 1 meaning it’s very highly correlated
Now add a scatter plot for
another stock, ABC,
and again each one of these dots represents
the daily return of SPY versus ABC,
and we fit a line to it, and
it turns out it's got a slope of two, so
now we're going to ask you
a couple of questions about it.